6 23 it is a Thursday morning and you
know what's back once again Las Vegas
days Rodeo it's going to be downtown
again over at the plaza at the court
Arena and as part of the event there's
the whiscarino contest to show off the
best beards the best mustaches whatever
you might have on your face that's been
growing we have to see if it's good if
you have what it takes there's still
time to register for that and everything
else joining us this morning Chris Neal
with Las Vegas days Rodeo Larry Rhea is
here with makeshift Union one of the
sponsors of whiscarino located in the
arts district gentlemen thanks for
waking up early it's a long Preamble we
got Las Vegas days Rodeo back Chris
let's talk about the rodeo it's been
around for such a long time it's kind of
moved around on the counter a little bit
but this is a big event it is it is
we're at 11 having it back here in Las
Vegas and uh it was originally in May
but now because of coven a few things I
had to change the timing up and I got it
where we could at least have it and it
was in November and so it's kind of
stayed there and we're just glad to keep
the history in the downtown area and
bring the rodeo go back and Las Vegas
state is formerly known as hell Dorado
such an important part of the the
history of Las Vegas and the pioneer
days as we would call it what can folks
expect maybe they're not sure what Las
Vegas days is and they know what a rodeo
would be what can they expect if they go
down there lots of good action so there
is uh we have a lot of NFR contestants
that's going to be in town for the NFR
of course that everyone knows about next
month that's coming into town but we
have lots of those contestants entered
here this week we have lots of also
livestock that'll be in the NFR so you
can pair that up with the contestants in
the livestock we're gonna have a good
show it's gonna be a while right behind
the plaza there right downtown now part
of this Larry is something that I think
is new this year it's actually similar
to that it's actually just returning
okay whisperino used to be an annual
event here in Las Vegas as well okay
fair enough I I don't have a whisperino
so I don't have I wasn't too familiar
Larry tell us about whiscarino what it's
all about and just kind of the fun of
having this contest uh right along with
the rodeo so uh whisker competitions are
about as old as you know Cowboys are
um and uh there's five different
categories there's longest beard longest
mustache best natural beard most
creative beard and also worst beard and
uh the the show is sponsored by my shop
makeshift Union we have prizes from the
plaza the sand dollar and Oscar's
Steakhouse as well okay and and the
worst what would Define the worst beard
patchy uh you haven't been to makeshift
Union yeah yeah exactly wispy patchy
um but you know that's cool too like
Keanu Reeves has a pretty bad beard
what is he here shots fired Keanu your
move buddy your move oh yeah uh Chris
just finally talking about we've got
whisperino going on and so much other
things how big this is to have Las Vegas
days Rodeo back once again this year
it's awesome you know um Las Vegas
Centennial commission thanked them in
the Plaza Hotel for bringing it back
they're sponsoring the event and it's
pretty admission by the way free
admission Friday night Saturday night 6
PM performance time doors open gates
open at 5 PM good deal and you're not
you're not going to take part in whisk
Arena though I don't think I can do that
I knew that way I got it where's my
beard well yeah we'll have the worst
ones Larry Chris thanks for joining us
this morning good to see whiscarino Las
Vegas days Rodeo back once again
appreciate it gentlemen thank you